[Music]
hey folks and welcome
to generation next or should i say
generation
now i already used that one so you made
that joke last week
i should i know we should just comment
called a generation now but this week
we are talking about scalpers and how
messed up it is that they managed to
grab
so many consoles and what if anything
retailers can do to combat it so to
discuss
i'm joined by xbox expert jordan remain
yo
and playstation pro to mo hussein hello
everyone
what a nice polite greeting i still
don't trust this like
no the last episode we had he led all
innocent
innocent-like
and then he dropped the other shoe at
the end of the episode don't know what
you're talking about
absolutely fine just because we had
thanksgiving break doesn't mean that
i've forgotten
no it's just given him more time to
think of some so
before we get to chan's let's jump
straight into it
tam do you want to give us
before time thinks of something
disgusting to say let's get right into
it tam do you want to give us the back
story on what's been
going on yes leslie i would love to give
you the backstory on what's going on
i'm trying to what are you doing i'm
waiting for the goose
i just hate some weed
everyone on edge that's my new thing
just keep everyone on the edge
so uh the thing that's happening here is
jordan
bots bots are happening here i think
we're familiar with bots that like you
know
on the twitter variety that i look
here's a picture of all the toilets in
video games shout out to
kelly but these are a different kind of
bots these are evil bots that are making
it hard for people to buy stuff
so this is a massive deal in the
trainer's slash sneaker market i knew i
was so
tam and i british and when i was putting
this run of show together i wrote
sneakers and i was like
i'm deliberately not going to say that
word british and we don't say that word
we say
what can
actually actually from my part of london
we call them crepes
so now you know why the uh reseller
group is called crep chief notify
um so uh sneakers the sneaker market and
getting you know
highly um sought after exclusive
sneakers
have become a bit of a cottage industry
now um
where it's valued the resale market for
sneakers especially is
valued at around 2 billion which is
ridiculous
and now we're in a situation where you
know they're kind of branching out
though the use of bots to purchase in
demand
items in bulk has branched out into
other
super in demand um uh items such as
the for example the nvidia 30 series of
graphics card
cards they were super difficult and they
still are super difficult to get because
they're impossible
today and there's still nothing so we
know a bunch of people who are in like
discords trying to track it and
resellers are eating up a lot of the
stock and now it's
spread to the playstation 5 and xbox
series x
now this is this kind of stuff happens a
lot like it happened with the wii
it happened with weirdly copies of
professor layton at one point i remember
it happening with
um yeah yeah for sure i was working
retail at that time and people would
come in and be like i need all of your
professor leighton's
um but now it's now it's more
sophisticated because they have
automated scripts running it
and you have the existence of reseller
groups like
for example crepe sheet not crepe chief
notifier which got according to reports
3 500 playstation 5
consoles using a reworked version of
their sneaker script buying bots
um so that's what's happening you can't
buy a console right now because there's
probably a bot
buying it and then selling it for a
premium
before we get too deep into the weeds on
how these bots work because
i went down a rabbit hole today um have
you guys ever bought anything
from a scalper and if you haven't would
you ever consider it what is like the
white whale item that you would
go to a scalp so when i worked retail
i had access to a lot of wheeze and i
had access to a lot of copies of
professor layton
[Laughter]
honestly yeah legitimately
got a selection of ds games on sale
stranger
um so what i did was i realized it was
happening and
obviously the company i work for which
will remain nameless didn't really care
it was just like if they're buying it
who cares so what i started doing was
buying the stock and selling them at the
purchase price that i got it for
and and doing on amazon so people
weren't buying through scalper so i was
an anti-scalper
so i took my stock of wheeze and
professor leighton's
went to amazon and sold them at normal
value
so gamer's version of robin hood over
here
to get back so
yeah i i have done that i've never
purchased anything from a scalper
because i just don't see the value in it
um i think the one thing i did purchase
for way higher than
um original its value was metal gear
solid twin snakes long after they'd gone
out of print
and i don't even like that game but it
was a metal gear thing and i was like i
guess i gotta buy it but i bought it for
like maybe 30 pounds more than it was
normally sold at i have not bought from
a scalper i was lucky to get a wii
an xbox 360. it wasn't hard to get an
xbox
one day one it just wasn't hard to get
that i
was tempted like i don't know if this
do you do you all have popeyes in the uk
do you remember last night are you
playing
i've had i've had a chicken sandwich are
you buying chicken sandwiches from
scalpers
like because there was just a period of
time where some people would like go in
and they would buy like 10 chicken
sandwiches and they would just leave and
like just stand in the parking lot and
sell
the sandwich and i really wanted one
town
i would never buy food from a person
just standing in a parking lot
i guess it's no different than an actual
like pop-up food store but like
just a dude with a bag of 10 sandwiches
absolutely not no chance i just wanted
to try
i didn't actually do it i just
considered it
what a world we used to live in where we
could one like shake hands and breathe
next to each other and also buy chicken
sandwiches from random people
in a parking lot that is wild
personally i have never bought anything
from a scalper the one thing
i remember looking into buying tickets
for oh my god who was it
it was a sold out show i think
adult no i think you're right it was
adele
it was for your mom no no my friend
ellie and i
and um i was looking at scalping
scalpers
uh who were selling tickets for adele
and they were so so expensive and uh
luckily we managed to get some
like in the final row like literally it
was the worst seats for any show i've
ever been in it was at wembley
and it took us two hours just to get to
the tube station which is right outside
the stadium
that was a long tangent to talk about
scalpers then maybe evan will have to
cut
no no i don't think i will
the long and short of it is obviously
scalpers have been in the news
a whole lot recently because increased
demand like uh
jim ryan from sony's saying like
literally everything is sold
you can't get anything new because it
keeps being brought up so quickly
jordan is it illegal to use
bots it should be but it's not it's not
illegal i mean because really all the
bots are doing
is it's alerting someone to when
something is going on
sale like right when it goes live and
sometimes allowing them to cut
in front of a queue line if there is
such a thing and then just get
access to the product and as long as you
have enough
addresses to send the product to and
enough cards for the
system to notify like oh this must be
different people
buying all of these products so quickly
in a row like
the retailers don't really care they're
still getting the money it doesn't
really matter
who's actually buying
it i guess i shouldn't say that they
might actually do care but
they're still getting the money so
there's really not a true i think
incentive for them to really crack down
on this
yet yeah so i went i was looking when i
was putting the runner show together
today i went down the rabbit hole
looking at stuff because there's
like you said there's a type of bot that
just alerts you to when stock is in
there's another kind that kind of uses
um compromised
ip addresses and stuff to make the
website think that you're coming at it
from different
like ips and stuff so there's that level
of it
um but it's funny that you said that
about retailers is so that i was reading
this bbc
article there is a quote from rob burke
former director of international
e-commerce
for game stop and he says
at times more than 60 of our traffic
across hundreds of millions of visitors
a day
was bots or scrapers especially in the
run-up to big launchers
on the one hand you just want to shift
the product so who cares if it's a bot
or a real customer
on the flip side if none or very few of
your real customers get the product with
you they will naturally go elsewhere
so just like you said why would a
retailer care because they
are still selling it and so this is this
is where i
went down a really big hole of research
is because
in some industries they do care and one
of those industries
is the music industry it's the chicken
sandwich industry
it's the chicken sandwich industry no so
it's like
basically we gave a very top-line view
of how bots and scalpers work
and actually there is an interview with
a scalper that i read
and i think he does work for um they
changed his name but i think he does
work for
crap chief notify and he basically was
saying that like the challenge isn't do
running the bots at all like the
challenge
is uh having enough cards and addresses
to assign all the stuff to
and he said that basically they don't
it like they don't see what they're
doing like reset like
taking all the stock and holding onto it
and reselling it for profit is a bad
thing and they actually kind of
blame the retailers
yeah i think that's i think they are
doing something wrong because they're
creating
a a kind of a a situation where they're
not available
which means they can also sell it at a
premium so if you're taking the
opportunity or the ability away from
people to buy at a normal price
and then being the only source of
available stock for
that that i am and then jacking up the
price to do it you are absolutely doing
something wrong don't try and
finesse me me i'll slap you upside your
head if you judge
it with me get banged that's how it
works
like
we're not doing anything wrong grow up
yes you are
but yes they're not doing anything
legally wrong it's
morally wrong it's legally wrong but i
like
i wanted to i wanted to bring this up as
a discussion piece speaking of morally
wrong because it's like
people buy stuff and flip it all the
time
like that is how ebay is a website
right it's like people buy stuff and
sell it hopefully for profit
um and so it's like this
scalping and especially when it comes to
consoles it feels like it's just doing
it in the extreme
um like if you go on ebay right now and
search for playstation 5 in hand xbox
series x in hand
god help me if you look for cyberpunk in
hand that's
going for like a thousand dollars but
like consoles that are costing
300 400 500 are going for double that
and it's like it's weird because the
moral quandary comes from
like it's 2020 what if you've lost your
job and you've hedged your bets on doing
this and flipping consoles is a
like i'm not like condoning it at all
but that's another moral
yeah but it sucks for the people on the
other end who like legitimate consumers
who just want to buy it and they can't
for me like when you're when you're this
group that is entirely focused on
creating scarcity around a hot topic and
then
putting a premium price on it you are
crossing that moral
line like and you're preventing
customers you're ruining the experiences
for customers like and
and places like gamestop might think oh
yeah that's fine
but it's also what what the um executive
said like
if you go to gamestop trying to buy a
console and this is one what the
experience you get
you're not going to come back to
gamestop the next time that happens
you're going to go somewhere else you're
going to be like whatever
i'm surprised like sony hasn't got more
involved because i would be annoyed if i
made something and said this is five
hundred dollars
and then someone else was like i'm gonna
buy all of those and sell them for one
thousand dollars
like i'm surprised that sony hasn't got
involved and been like i mean like
there's nothing they can really do but
like
it sucks for people who are like yeah
i'm a paying customer i'm having to pay
like and there's a certain type of
person that can then afford that right
like you're not selling it to to to just
a run-of-the-mill
person who's super into games you're
selling it to people or just this when
this happened
with like in in the retail it was a
certain type of person that came in and
sold
bought a bunch of them took them to a
place where a part of london where they
knew
that rich people lived and sold it all
to them and that was uh that's how they
got christmas presents for
for you know their friends and family
and loved ones and that's what made me
do the thing i did also that's really
because there's a mom come in and like
just wants to buy it for a
kid and like you know it's an average
kind of person and
she ain't got a chance of buying that
kind of stuff it's weird that you know
there was that um tweet that went viral
like last week or so it's like
all these adults buying ps5s um
taking them away from kids on christmas
morning and stuff it's like at this rate
mate
no one's getting one it's almost
impossible so
let's discuss um i mentioned the
beginning episode like
what can retailers do about it you said
it just then like what can gamestop and
target and best buy do about it and it
turns out like
not a lot um like we said it's not
illegal technically some of it is
borderline fraud
um because you are pretending to be
like from different ip addresses and
sometimes they've been compromised so
it's technically borderline but not
enough to be convicted
but when i mentioned earlier that some
industries do care about this
the music industry is um very
like in the uk at least cracked down on
this uh so in 2017 there was a digital
economy bill
in the uk that uh wanted to make it
illegal to use bots to bypass
limits on buying tickets for events and
people who did that can face unlimited
fines
and that's been enforced since july 2018
originally so this was even more
interesting so it's like really good
that that went through
originally it was going to be an offense
to even use
digital purchase purchasing software to
purchase
excess event tickets how would they
possibly police that
that's the thing that got withdrawn
internet
that part got withdrawn so like yeah
because how can you
i don't know what counts as excessive i
guess some events
god remember going to events they'd be
like okay you can go see
metallica in concert but you can only
buy six tickets so maybe it was like
if you bought more than that but i guess
yeah i guess they could like focus
on addresses that are like why is there
70 tickets going to one address
i mean well interestingly uh they did
arrest
and um prosecute two resellers in the uk
who made 11 million pounds
oh doing resale stuff for
cursed child harry potter and the cursed
child ed sheeran and taylor swift
tickets
so this this is technically illegal in
the uk it's awesome
use of the tech was made a criminal
offense in new york because a report
found that one bot
had bought a thousand tickets in one
minute
for a u2 concert at madison madison
square garden
that can't be real what so
like the legislation is there in some
places
um however it's not enforced
around the world although i'm amazed
like it's just it just seems to be for
music and events
right now so nothing about
uh consoles or anything or graphics
cards
well i almost wonder like and this is
just me speculating there's
no basis behind like what i'm saying if
it's almost
music is one of those things that like
tickets have been sold digitally like
for ever like at this point like for
things like
consoles like in previous years and
generations whenever we got new
consoles there were always like select
numbers that like
best buy in gamestop would just hold
like on
sites like you have to actually come
into the store and buy it yourself and
now that we're in a pandemic like
everyone's buying stuff digitally so it
was like completely digital
purchases for consoles this time around
and like
we just might not be prepared to
acknowledge that there are other
aspects of our capitalist hellscape that
need to be monitored for digital
purchases
yeah that's the thing so uh one group um
managed to
uh exploit a link to a uk retailer and
got a thousand
series x consoles um and then sky news
dubbed them in
and so the reta the retailer but the
thing is
this is the issue here it's like the
retailer went in and cancelled
these orders that they thought were
suspicious but they accidentally
canceled some
legit orders as well so
there is no easy way of doing it like
the one thing one
method that i found that a retailer used
is curry's pc world
in the uk um listed the consults
at 2 000 pounds more than they actually
cost
and if you were a registered user and
you'd properly pre-ordered
um i think there was like a token or
something they would send
they would email you your code um
to a 2 000 pound discount code
um so you had to pay five pounds
to like properly pre-order then they
would send you
this thing and you couldn't copy paste
the
actual um code
to activate it so you'd actually type it
in yourself you had to physically type
it in so to get around bots that way
which is really really clever but it's
like
it's it's wild yeah that's also like a
dangerous game as well like you make
some mistakes then someone's paying two
grand for something
yeah so that's what retailers are doing
but in terms of like
actual uh like facebook marketplace
is rife so is ebay
one of the things i've enjoyed doing is
reverse image searching the picture that
i posted when i got my ps5
and seen just how many facebook
marketplace and
retweet to win um tweets it's appeared
in
which is a lot so always do that always
make sure your reverse image so
just take a picture like i did like take
a picture of something in the foreground
and put the console in the background
like my screwdriver picture oh yeah your
screwdriver is very good
but it's like yeah it's probably the
same question it's like why aren't they
doing anything
yeah it's not technically illegal i
don't think they're like
like where facebook for example they
don't give
crap what you're selling there you see
some of the stuff in there i've seen
some absurd things in there they're just
taking their paintings
and moving on yeah they're just they
don't care they're like yeah you can buy
that we're here to steal your
information not your money that's
meaningless to us
ebay ebay is just the nightmare
hellscape anyway so
um yeah i'm not surprised it does suck
and the thing is like the tricky thing
is like people want to give
gifts right now because one it's the
holiday season to
gifts right now are all that's kind of
lifting a lot of people's spirits but
if you can just hold out hold out for a
little longer until the restocks happen
and all this dies down you won't have to
stress yourself out about this stuff
and you'll be able to pay a normal price
if this always happens like there's
always like scarcity around things and
then the scalpel stuff happens and
after a while it just like calms down
and things are normally available again
it's wild anyway so i thought we'd cover
it this week and just talk about it and
kind of
explain a bit why it happens and
hopefully there'll be a work card like
it is wild that it has to be it seems to
have to be
the legal uh i know
like the legislators have to get we've
got eight to nine years to fix this
before
the new consoles come around again
um but anyway thank you for joining us
once again
jordan where can people find you you can
find me on twitter at jmremay
and tam
still nothing interesting all right
and i'm at lucy james games we'll see
you next week absolutely
you